könnt ihr euch ein blutiges rindes track
zum frühstück vorstellen das thema
fleisch polarisiert und wird in
deutschland zu recht sehr heiß
diskutiert abgesehen von moralischen und
umweltbezogenen bedenken vor allem auch
der ernährungs aspekt während die
meisten sagen zu viel fleisch ist
ungesund aber wenig ist okay gibt es
natürlich einige die sagen absolute
verzicht auf fleisch sein gesündesten
und wiederum andere die sagen man sollte
zum großteil fleisch essen spricht ein
zitat bzw paléo aus eigenem interesse
werde ich einen bluttest bei einem arzt
machen und nicht wegen und dann diese
woche ausschließlich fleisch gewürze und
wasser zu mir nehmen kann er wurst kann
brot kann obst kann gemüse keine säfte
und auch nichts süßes ich werde
berichten wie es mir dabei geht ob
mangelerscheinungen auftreten wie sich
dabei mein gewicht verändert und
anschließend erneut blut abnehmen lassen
um herauszufinden wie sich die fleisch
diät auf meine gesundheit aber auch auf
meinen geldbeutel auswirkt dieses video
wird unterstützt von blink ist bevor man
experiment startet wird sich erst mal
gewogen 68 kilogramm
danach geht's ab zum arzt für eine
blutabnahme um eine momentaufnahme
meiner gesundheit zu erhalten
kleiner einschub aus der zukunft die
blutwerte sind jetzt angekommen alles im
grünen bereich abgesehen von den
leberwerten wir sind etwas erhöht der
arzt meint er das liegt in der regel an
übergewicht konnten wir uns beide dann
nicht erklären ein typischer tag in
unserer küche sieht normal ticker so aus
ich frühstücke vollkornbrot mit
magerquark und olivenöl oder lasse das
frühstück wegfallen
zum mittagessen kommt meine freundin oft
etwas ausgefallenes in der regel vegan
oder vegetarisch und immer mit viel
gemüse die koch videos auf ihrem kanal 4
bieten den ganz guten einblick in unsere
küche zu abend wird dann entweder das
mittagessen aufgewärmt oder es gibt brot
mit avocado käse und gemüse
zwischendrin hauptsächlich obst aber
auch mal was süßes trinken tue ich zu
circa 85 prozent nur wasser zu 10%
fünfte und zu fünf prozent tee und
fleisch gibt es bisher circa ein bis
zweimal die woche
ich bin echt mal gespannt wie sich diese
woche aus wirkt einerseits macht mir die
schiere menge an fleisch gesundheitlich
echt wirklich angst und ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass das annähernd für
meinen körper gut sein kann andererseits
wird aber in ernährung studien auch so
gut wie immer der normalverbraucher
betrachtet ja auch ohne seine wurst und
anderes verarbeitetes fleisch ist ich
werde ja ausschließlich unverarbeitetes
reines fleisch essen und dadurch auch
auf ganz viele andere umstrittene
lebensmittel verzichten
wer weiß mehr alle milchprodukte und
natürlich auch zucker der
durchschnittsdeutsche ist pro jahr circa
60 kg bzw pro tag ca 164 gramm fleisch
wenn man davon ausgeht dass ich
weiterhin wie bisher ca 2000 800
kilokalorien pro tag essen will muss ich
ab sofort zwei kilo fleisch essen jeden
tag also zum beispiel 400 gramm
rindersteak 150 gramm schweinefleisch
600 gramm hähnchenbrust und 800 gramm
hähnchenschenkel dafür geht es ab in den
biomarkt meines vertrauens
gesundheitlich lässt sich über fleisch
zwar streiten aber umwelttechnisch ist
viehzucht natürlich eine katastrophe und
auch moralisch ist die art in der tiere
gehalten werden alles andere als
unbedenklich beim discounter sowieso
aber leider bestimmt auch beim einem
biomarkt bei dem ich trotz aktionspreis
satte 13 eur 54 für diese 400 gramm
rinderhüfte liegen gelassen habe so ich
komme auch eine frisch vom arzt und dann
im supermarkt ihre königliche wo sie
jetzt steak frühstück gibt beste
tageszeit für so nen guten körper
[Musik]
ich glaube das ist das allererste mal
dass ich mir in rindersteaks derselbe
antwortet meine straße gehen jetzt
einfach relativ scharf anzubraten und
darauf hoffen dass es in natürlich noch
ein bisschen rosa bleibt so aufgeht ich
bin gespannt wie das schmeckt zu
komplett ohne alles und stück weit zu
durch für meinen geschmack aber ist noch
im rahmen des machbaren ich habe das
persönlich gar kein problem mit fleisch
zum frühstück zu essen er schmeckt auf
jeden fall auch nur mit salz richtig
lecker die frage ist nur bleibt das auch
so wenn ich sieben tage lang nur das
esse ich dachte eines tag machen muss
hat ist aber gar nicht wo ich muss man
jetzt noch ein zweites antworten nachdem
ich auch das gegessen habe gebe ich die
mahlzeit in einen ernährung strecke ein
ein frühstück beinhaltet also null gramm
kohlenhydrate 12 gramm fett und 86 gramm
eiweiß so die beiden stücke schwein
wegen mir auch kilogramm leichter
mittags auf jonathan gegessen habe ich
jetzt einfach beide direkt rein zu viel
ist einfach dreist wiese ist ein stück
kuchen
also so ein bisschen was süßes hätte ich
tatsächlich jetzt auch gerne muss ich
ganz ehrlich zugeben zweiten mal zeit
ausschließlich fleisch auf geht's
deutlich verzögern natürlich hey ich
würde wirklich töten jetzt für ein stück
brot und ein paar kartoffeln oder
kartoffelsalat ich gebe es wieder in
unserem fitness trecker ein da kommen
gegen ich diesmal auf 3,6 gramm
kohlenhydrate tatsächlich 60 gramm fett
und wieder 62 gramm eiweiß bereits am
zweiten tag wird mir beim bloßen
gedanken an blankes fleisch bereits so
übel dass sich das frühstück ausfallen
lassen muss und das mittagessen auch
19.35 uhr ist gebäuden ich habe erst
jetzt genug hunger als dass ich wieder
lust hätte fleisch zu essen weil ich
sagen hier den kunden schenken da war
schon immer dass wir haben jetzt keinen
neuen gekauft und meiner freundin soll
ich das gute stück jetzt aber mal
anbraten dann wäre es noch schöner
respekt und das erst danach in offenbach
[Musik]
pfeffer salz chili koma paprikapulver
und kreuzkümmel ich heute einfach mal
drauf man paprika noch mal andere
paprika und hier haben noch mal eine
andere paprika da ist wenn ich mal eine
gewürzmischung und die schönheit hier
die wieder zu den ofen
oder sieht richtig lecker aus aufgeht
sie hat mittlerweile so krass hunger ist
es 9 uhr wirklich punkt 9 ich hab auch
nichts gegessen hatte das ist einfach
ein unterschied wie tag und nacht
braucht man jetzt ein fettes ungewisses
schweinefleisch ist oder schön gewürze
gute glaube so kann ich die woche schon
eher überstehen
die neue lieferung ist auch hier sind
die guten
ich würde sagen ich mache ich wieder
ähnlich wie gestern oder sophia idee
nicht noch machen könnte ok also einmal
dass man mal drauf macht kummer kardamon
kardamom muskat muskatnuss muss kaputt
haben wir auch musk als blüte sind sind
kreuzkümmel es immer gut wenn und demand
mir fällt mir sicher perfekt wie hat die
frau gehört
so ist jetzt extrem gut angebraten
könnte schon sagen fast zu gut
angebraten schaufenster aufrecht so das
sieht wirklich lecker aus ich möchte
auch immer mega lecker ich habe bock auf
fleisch gerade so jetzt habe ich für die
kamera mit gabel und messer gegessen
jetzt kann ich endlich richtig essen
auch wenn ich immer noch maximal zwei
mahlzeiten zu mir nehme ist die lust auf
fleisch wieder zurück das 70 euro haben
jetzt gar nicht mehr angeboten so das
ist richtig rosa in noch sein sollte es
lag also obwohl sie jetzt wirklich schon
ruhe ist kann es nicht wenn ich gut auch
wenn allein mein abendessen 1300
kilokalorien hat komme ich auch am tag
vier mit insgesamt 1700 kilokalorien
leider nicht annähernd an meine
normalwert von 2800 so etwas ganz
besonderes die sophie hat mir ein live
gezeigt mit dem man einfach hündchen da
rein machen hier in seiner tüte
[Musik]
ich wollte jetzt gerade einkaufen gehen
und dann ist man gefallen es ist sonntag
also bleiben denn eigentlich nichts
anderes über außer zu verhungern oder
mir was vom lieferdienst zu bestellen
und einfach schauen dass er möglichst
keine beilage dabei ist hilft statement
vom frites und salat die beilage gebe
ich dann also viel aber das heute klar
gehen heute war der letzte tag ich habe
den ganzen tag daran gedacht endlich mal
ein stück kuchen reinzubeißen oder der
portionen zu verdrücken
dieses bedürfnis nach coli warten und
morgen um 9 uhr 45 ist der 18
das experiment ist endlich zu ende als
allererstes geht es auf die waage
65 kilo das heißt ich habe in diesen
acht tagen ganze drei kilo verloren weil
ich nicht mehr essen konnte uns das ist
für mich nichts gutes danach geht es
direkt zur zweiten blutabnahmen während
das labor meine blutwerte aus vehrte hat
die sophie ein festmahl zubereitet ok
und jetzt nach acht tagen an denen ich
nur fleisch gegessen habe jetzt erst mal
war schön königreiches mit frischem
gemüse und vitamin a
ich musste mein kind richtig lecker das
ist auch so ziemlich genau das gegenteil
von dem was sie ja die ganze woche
gegessen hat schön viel gemüse tofu so
ziemlich das gegenteil vom tisch wenn
ihr wissen wollt wie das gekocht wurde
sophie hat gerade ein video aufgenommen
das ist natürlich bringt das erste mal
nach acht tagen obst das schmeckt
einfach so hipp hinten ich genauso
spannend das erste mal zucker und jetzt
ich weiß dass ihr euch denken so ist er
denn spekulatius cremig war das bedrückt
aber es gibt nichts heftiger dass diese
gehen und direkt versucht
jetzt sowieso relativ selten sie könnten
acht tage lang wenn ich die position
zusätzlich ich habe mich eigentlich
drauf eingestellt jetzt noch lange zu
warten aber am selben tag hat mir gerade
der arzt eine e mail geschickt letztlich
gibt es nach der woche protein pur nur
eine wesentliche veränderung die
harnsäure ist erwartungsgemäß gestiegen
und liegt außerhalb der normen heißt
langfristig gefahr von nicht
die übrigen werte sind nur unwesentlich
verändert und nach einer woche nicht
wegweisend aber immerhin drei kilogramm
abgenommen auch wenn sie dies sicher
nicht gebraucht hätten
der leberwerte warum auch immer der das
jetzt wieder im grünen bereich muss
jetzt nichts mit fleisch zu tun dann
kann auch messfehler sein oder kann auch
eine beschränkung sein
so sind die werte hat sich ansonsten
nichts wirklich verändert und mein gott
ich werde jetzt wohl an kein fleisch
mehr essen ernährung ist ein unpassender
wichtiges aber leider auch total
komplexes thema zudem jeden monat
dutzende heißt widersprüchliche studien
erscheinen aber das buch der ernährungs
compass das fazit aller
wissenschaftlichen studien zum thema
ernährung mit den zwölf wichtigsten
regeln der gesunden ernährung bringt
licht ins dunkel bei blinkt ist dem
sponsor des heutigen videos gibt es
unzählige hörbücher wie dieses die man
beim aufräumen sport oder autofahren
hören kann
klink ist ist bekannt für die
revolutionäre zusammenfassung von
büchern mit der man die essenz eines
buches in der circa 15 minuten anhören
oder durch lesen kann oder sogar in 75
minuten mit doppelter geschwindigkeit
wenn euch die zusammenfassung gepackt
hat könnt ihr jetzt jederzeit noch
tiefer einfach mit häufig und in voller
länge
es gibt ratgeber zeitlose klassiker und
bestseller aus produktivität ernährung
wissenschaft persönliche entwicklung und
viele mehr
auf deutsch und auf englisch und jeden
monat kommen circa 40 neue titel in 25
verschiedenen kategorien hinzu auf
blinkt ist punkt de / tory könnt ihr
sieben tage lang so viele bücher
verschlingen wie ihr wollt meine
zuschauer erhalten exklusiv 20 prozent
rabatt auf das jahres-abo blickes
premium ganz oben in der video
beschreibung linke.de ist oneriot im
nächsten video werde ich innerhalb von
einer woche das hacken wenn ihr das also
nicht verpassen und mich auf dieser
reise begleiten möchte dann abonniert
diesen kanal und dann sehen wir uns
demnächst mal wieder macht's gut
[Musik]